nos dicen un mono se balancea en un
árbol en su primera oscilación hace un
arco de 24 metros en cada oscilación
siguiente hace un arco de un medio la
longitud de la oscilación anterior bien
veamos qué pasa aquí
si tenemos aquí el punto superior de la
cuerda donde el mono se balancea déjame
dibujar a mi pequeño mono entonces la
primera oscilación se desplaza 24 metros
en un arco como este este arco es de 24
metros y en la siguiente oscilación va
de regreso pero hace un arco de la mitad
de la longitud de la oscilación anterior
así que va en sentido contrario pero la
segunda vez que se balancea tiene una
oscilación de la mitad tal vez por aquí
entonces serían 12 metros y en la
siguiente oscilación sería la mitad de
eso tal vez se ve algo así son 6 metros
y todo esto tiene sentido esto es
consistente con nuestra experiencia
balanceando no sé
árboles para los que se hayan con
limpiado alguna vez así que veamos que
nos preguntan en el primer inciso
qué expresión nos da la longitud total
del balanceo del mono después de sus
primeras en oscilaciones bueno pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrar la respuesta
correcta y techo expresado de dos
maneras distintas expresarlo como una
serie geométrica y expresa lo como la
suma de un asociación geométrica si
fuera posible evaluar la serie
bien vamos a trabajar juntos nos dicen
que la primera oscilación del mono se
desplaza a 24 metros ok
en la segunda oscilación y es que de
hecho quise darte una pista cuando te
dije que expreses esta distancia como
una serie geométrica porque en la
segunda oscilación es la mitad de estos
24 metros podría simplemente escribir un
12 aquí pero un medio es un número
interesante ya que es mi razón común
débil serie geométrica cada siguiente
oscilación tendrá un arco que tendrá la
mitad de la longitud del arco de la
oscilación anterior es decir será 24 por
un medio y el siguiente arco será la
mitad de la anterior es decir 24 por un
medio por un medio o dicho de otra
manera 24 por un medio elevado a la
segunda potencia así que aquí tenemos
los tres primeros arcos y observa que en
este momento
estamos elevando la segunda potencia
entonces la longitud de las primeras n
oscilaciones será todo de esta suma
hasta sumar a 24 por un medio elevado a
la potencia y ten cuidado no es la
potencia n es la potencia n menos 1
puedes pensar que después de dos
oscilaciones escribimos 24 por un medio
elevado la primera potencia después de
tres oscilaciones escribimos 24 por un
medio elevado la segunda potencia y así
que después de en oscilaciones será un
medio elevado en la potencia n menos 1
ahora bien no sólo queremos tener esta
expresión también te pedí que la evalúe
y la forma de evaluarla es pensar en la
fórmula para series geométricas finitas
que hemos aprendido y demostrado en
vídeos anteriores déjame escribir qué
nos dice nos dice que la suma de los
primeros n términos
igual am y bueno es igual a a donde es
el primer término que en este caso es 24
entonces tengo a menos a por r donde r
es la razón común que en este caso es un
medio elevado a la potencia n
una forma de recordar esto es pensar en
la diferencia del primer término menos
el primer término de la sucesión que aún
no incluimos o puedes pensarlo como el
primer término después de éste y bueno
todo esto entre 1 - la razón común hay
otra forma de escribir esto mismo a
veces factorizar la app y obtenemos am
que multiplica a 1 - r elevado a la n
entre 1 - r y estas dos expresiones son
equivalentes bueno pero ahora usemos la
de hecho vamos a usar esta segunda forma
de escribir la fórmula esto será igual a
nuestro primer término que es 24 que
multiplica a 1 - la razón común que es
un medio elevado a la n como nos piden
la longitud total después de sus
primeras en los citaciones dejar
y esto es / 1 - nuestra razón común
1 - un medio y ahora podemos dejarlas y
yo podemos simplificar un poco en
nuestro denominador tengo 1 menos un
medio que es un medio y 24 dividido por
un medio es 48 así que esto se
simplifica en 48 que multiplica a 1
menos un medio elevado a la n cualquiera
de estas dos son respuestas correctas y
la segunda pregunta nos dice cuál es la
distancia total que se ha metido el mono
después de su 25a para oscilación
redondea tu respuesta final al metro
entero más cercano bien pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la respuesta bueno
podemos usar esta expresión de aquí para
obtener la respuesta sabemos que después
de completar 25 oscilaciones n es igual
a 25
entonces reemplazar a n con 25 y me
quedara 48 que multiplica a 1
o menos un medio elevado a la 25 y bueno
un medio elevado a la 25 será un número
muy muy pequeño será muy cercano a 0 y
por lo tanto todo esto será muy cercano
a 48 metros pero veamos con cuidado el
resultado y recuerda habrá que redondear
lo al metro entero más cercano
muy bien vamos a traer nuestra
calculadora y primero encontremos el
resultado de un medio elevado a la 25
eso es lo mismo que 0.5 elevado a la 25
que como predije es un número muy
pequeño
después realizaré esta diferencia así
que le pondré un signo negativo y la
suma de uno observa obtuvimos algo muy
cercano a 1 así que sigue vigente mi
predicción y si multiplicamos esto por
48 y lo redondeamos al metro entero más
cercano regresamos a 48 metros así que
lo escribiré el resultado de esta
segunda pregunta es 48 metros y hemos
terminado